you've mentioned to brian keating
that you may be releasing a geometric
community paper
this year or some other form of
additional material
in the topic what is your thinking
around this
what's the process you're going through
now well it's very interesting this
i i used april 1st to try to start a
tradition
which i hope to use to liberate mankind
the tradition is that at least one day a
year
you should be able to say heretical
things
and not have jack dorsey boot you off or
mark zuckerberg
your provost shouldn't call you up and
say what did you say
we need at some level to have a jubilee
from centralized control and so
my my hope is that you know what a
tradition is in america
something a baby boomer did twice
impeachment that's very funny
anyway um so when i'm i'm not a baby
boomer but as an exer
i thought about whether or not april 1st
would be a good date
on which to release a printed version of
what i already
said in lecture form because i think
it's hysterically funny that the physics
community claims
that it can't decode video a lecture
yeah i
it must be paper and you know what there
will be a steady stream of new
complaints
up until the point that they fit it into
a narrative that they like
um yeah i'm thinking about april 1st
as a date in which to release a document
and it won't be perfectly complete but
it'll be very complete
and then they'll try to say it's wrong
or you already did it or
no that was dumb but what we just did on
top of it is brilliant
or it doesn't match experiment or who
knows what they'll go through all of
their usual nonsense
it's time to go is there still puzzles
in your own mind
that need to be figured out for you to
try to put it on paper i mean
those are different mediums right it was
a good great question
i did not count on something that turns
out to be important
when you work on your own outside of the
system for a long time you probably
don't think you're going to be doing
this as a 55 year old
man and i have been so long outside of
math and physics departments and i've
been occupied with so many other things
as you can see
that the old idea that i had was if i
always did it in little pieces
then i was always safe because it
wouldn't be stealable
and so now those pieces never got
assembled
completely in essence i have all the
pieces
and i can fit them together
but there's probably a small amount of
glue code
like there are a few algebraic things
i've forgotten how to do i may or may
not figure them out between now and
april
1st but it's pretty complete but that's
the puzzle you're kind of uh
struggling to now figure out to get it
all on
the glue together i can't tell you
whether the theory is correct or
incorrect
but like you know for example there's
what's the exact form of the super
symmetry algebra or
how what's the rule for passing a minus
sign through a particular operator
and all of that stuff got a lot more
difficult because i didn't
i didn't do it every look you know it's
a little bit like
uh if you're you know if you're a
violinist and you don't touch your
violin regularly
for 15 years you come back to it you
pretty much know the pieces sort of but
there's lots of stuff that's missing
your tone is off and that kind of stuff
i would say i've got i'll get the ship
to the harbor and it'll require a
tugboat
probably to get it in and if the tugboat
doesn't show up then i'll pilot the
thing right into the dock myself but
it's not a big deal i think that
it is essentially complete
psychologically
just as a human being this is uh i
remember
perhaps by accident but maybe there's no
accidents in the universe
i was tuned in i don't remember where on
april 1st
yeah to you uh oh i think i knew discord
yeah uh kind of thinking about thinking
through this release i mean it wasn't
like
uh it wasn't obvious that you were going
to do it you were thinking through it
and i remember there was
intellectual personal psychological
struggle with this
yeah right well because i did i thought
it was dangerous if this
turns out to be right i don't know what
it unlocks
i'm if it's wrong i think i
understand where we are if it's wrong
it'll be the first
fool's gold that really looks like a
theory of everything
it'll be the iron pyrites of physics and
we haven't even had fool's gold in my
opinion yet
got it so what is your intuition why
this
looks right to you like why it feels
like
it would be if if wrong i can say it
very simply
it's way smarter than i am can you break
that apart a little more
like every time you poke at it it's
giving you intuitions that follow with
the the currently known physical let's
put it in computer science terms
yes please okay there's a concept of
technical debt
that computer scientists struggle with
as you commit
crimes you have to pay those crimes back
at a later date
in general most of the problem with
physical theories is that
as you try to do something that matches
reality you usually have to go into some
structure
that gets you farther away and your hope
is is that you're going to be able to
pay back the technical debt and
in general these wind up as check hiding
schemes
or like you're funding a startup and
they're too many pivots
right so you keep adding epicycles in
order to
to cover things that have gone wrong
my belief is is that
this thing represents something like a
summit
to me and i'm very proud of having found
a route up this summit
but the route is what's due to me the
summit
can't possibly be due to me
you know it's like edmund hillary and
tensing norgay
did not create mount everest they know
that they didn't create that they
figured out a way up
you got to tell me what uh mont everest
is in this metaphor
relative and also connected to the
technical debt so technical debt isn't
is a negative thing that
it's kind of you you'll eventually have
to pay it
are you saying in the in the ascent that
you're seeing
now the theory is you do not have much
technical debt well that's right i think
that what happens is that early on
what i would say is i believe now
that the physics community
has said many things incorrectly
about the current state of the universe
they're not
wildly off which is why like for example
the claim is that there are three
generations of matter i do not believe
that there are three generations matter
i believe that there are two generations
of matter and there is a third
collection that looks like a generation
of matter
as the first two only at low energy
okay well that's not a frequent claim
people imagine that there are three or
more generations of matter
i would claim that that's false people
claim that the matter is chiral that is
it knows it's left from its right
i would claim that the chirality is not
fundamental but it is emergent
we could keep going at all these sorts
of things people think that
space time is the fundamental geomatic
geometrical construct
i do not agree i think it's something
that i've termed the observers
all of these different things
represent a series of
over-interpretations
of the world that preclude progress
so you you gave i think you gave uh some
credit to string theory
as uh string theory i think loop quantum
gravity if i remember correctly
as as like getting close to the
fool's uh gold well i said that garrett
lisi
apparently phenomenologically gets
a lot of things right he gets he's got a
reason for chirality
a reason for uniqueness using e8 in fact
e8 uses something called vile fermions
which are chiral
he has a way of getting geometry
to get riemann's geometry underneath
general relativity to play with
aerosman's geometry which is underneath
the standard model using something
called cartan connections that are out
of favor
he's figured out something involving
super connections
to make sure that the fermion the matter
in the system isn't quantized
the same way as the bosons were which is
a problem in his old theory
he's got something about three
generations for triality he's got a lot
of phenomenological hits
i don't think garrett's theory works it
also has a very simple lagrange
basically using the yang mills
norm squared the same thing you would
use as a as a cost function
uh if you were doing neural nets okay
the string theorists have a different
selling point which is is that they may
have gotten a renormalizable theory of
gravity if quantum gravity was what we
were meant to do
and they've done some stuff with black
holes that they can get some solutions
correct and then they have lots of
agreements with where they show
mathematical
truths that mathematicians didn't even
know
i'm very underwhelmed by string theory
based on how many people
have worked on it and how little is
supporting the claims to it being a
theory of everything
but those are the two that i take
quite seriously i don't yet take
wolframs
quite seriously because if he really
finds one of these
cellular automatons that are really
distinct and generative
it'll be amazing but he's looking for
such a thing i don't think he's
found anything tag mark i view as a
philosopher
who is somehow taking credit for
platonism which
i don't see any reason for fighting with
max because i like max but
if it ever comes time i'm putting a
post-it note that i'm not positive the
mathematical universe hypothesis
is really anything new um
and in general uh loop quantum gravity
really i think grew out of some hopes
that the general relativistic community
had for
that they would be able to do particle
theory and i don't think that they've
shown
any particle theoretic realism so
essentially
here's what i really think lex
i think we didn't understand how big the
difference between
an effective theory and a theory of
everything is conceptually
maybe it's not mathematically that
different
but conceptually trying to figure out
what a theory of every how does the
universe and i've compared it to
escher's drawing hands
how do two hands draw themselves into
existence
that's the puzzle that i think has just
been wanting and i i'll be honest i'm
really surprised
that the theoretical physics community
um
he didn't even get up on their high
horse
and say this is the most stupid nonsense
imaginable
because clearly i'm i always say i'm not
a physicist
so i'm just a i'm i'm i'm an amateur
with a heart as big as all outdoors
so in your journey of releasing this and
i'm sure there
further maybe uh it will be another
american tradition on april 1st
that will continue for years
in my uh there's sort of
uh crumbs along the way that i'm hoping
to uh collect in my naive view of things
of the beauty that
in your geometric view of the universe
so uh one question
i'd like to ask is
if you were to challenge me to visualize
something beautiful
something important about geometric
community in my struggle to
appreciate some of its beauty from the
outsiders perspective
what would that thing be interesting
question
perhaps we can both have a journey
towards april 1st
take a look at that
some kind of a scrunchie that i picked
up on melrose
not melrose montana in santa monica
now you'll notice that all of those
discs
rotate independently yes
if you rotate groups of those in a way
that is continuous but not uniform
everywhere what you're doing is the
so-called gauge transformation
on the torus seen as a u1 bundle over a
u1
spacetime so the concept of space-time
here in a
very simplified case isn't
four-dimensional but it's
one-dimensional it's just a circle
and there's a circle above every point
in the circle represented by those
little disks
imagine if you will that
we took a rubber band
and placed it around here and decided
that that was a function
from the circle into this circle that is
representing a y-axis that's wrapped
around itself
well you would have an idea of what it
means for a function to be constant
if it just went all around the outside
but what happens if i
turn this a little bit then the function
would be mostly constant it would have a
little place where it dipped
and it went back it turns out that you
can
transform that function and transform
the derivative
that says that function is equal to zero
when i take its derivative
at the same time that's what a gauge
transformation is
amazing to me that we don't have
a simple video visualizing
things that i've already had built
and that i can clearly demonstrate when
you do that
taurus who's the code of the taurus is
itself
generating yeah this is a u1 principle
bundle
and the world needs to know what a gauge
theory is not by analogy
not with lawrence krauss saying it's
like a checkerboard if you change some
of the colors this way not saying
you know that it it's it's a
local symmetry involving it's none of
those things it's a theory of
differential calculus where the
functions
and the derivatives are both subject to
a particular kind of change
so that if a function was constant under
one derivative
then the new function is constant under
the new derivative
transformed in the same fashion and
would you put that under the category of
just
gauge transformations yes that would be
gauge transformations applied to
sections
and connections where connections are
the derivatives in the theory
this is easily explained it is
pathological that the community of
people who understand what i'm saying
have never bothered
to do this in a clear fashion for the
general public you and i could visualize
this
overnight this is not hard
the public needs to know in some sense
that let's say quantum electrodynamics
the theory of photons and electrons more
or less electrons are functions
and photons are derivatives now there's
some
you can object in some ways but
basically a gauge theory is the way in
which you can translate
uh a shift in the definition
of the functions and the shift of the
definition of the derivatives so that
the underlying physics is not harmed
or changed so you have to do both at the
same time now you and i can visualize
that so if what you wanted to do
rather than going directly to geometric
unity is that i could sit down with you
and i could say here are the various
components of geometric unity
and if the public needs a visualization
in order to play along
we've got a little bit over two months
and i'd be happy to work with you
i love that as a challenge and i'll take
it on and i hope we do make it happen
you